Hey,
what's going on is bill burn?
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
June 28th,
uh,
2015.
How you doing?
How,
why,
yeah,
how are you?
How are you?
How are fucking you?
Um,
I am completely burnt out.
I'm at the end of my tour right now and a,
I have to leave for my show in Tucson and exactly one hour.
So I'm going to do a half hour of this podcast and then do my show and then I'm
going to finish it up after the show.
So what you're basically going to have his stone sober.
Me Doing the first 30 minutes and then a slightly more slightly older,
slightly wide.
They're slightly more buzzed.
Um,
Billy red face during the second half of the podcast because that's how this is
going down and I have to be somewhere immediately.
Of course the second I fucking land cause that's how it works.
I'm in this business.
It's how it works out.
Why they owe.
You going to have a little breather there.
You're going to have a Brita.
Was this fucking Yank that right off the table?
But it could always be worse.
I could have absolutely nothing to do staring at a phone like that crazy bitch
in that movie.
The audition.
You guys ever see that bear with that and she was sticking the needles in that
fucker.
That's what you get for trying to bank some crazy actress,
you know,
if they're not sticking needles into your literally,
right.
Listen to me having the nerve to act like I'm on TV.
I'm even remotely sane.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
this is the last night of the tour.
I want to thank everybody that has come out on this one and I want to thank Joe
Barton Nick for absolutely crushing it right up until a Wednesday.
Baker's field,
the last one and then fucking,
uh,
j law had came in after fucking Barton.
It gave me a strong seven innings.
I went to the bullpen,
you know,
he gave me six and two thirds.
Then he walked up the next pattern.
Then I brought in fucking brought in law,
had lie,
had crushed it and um,
it was a crazy week of shows them we did,
uh,
did someplace in the inland empire.
And a 98% of the people were cool there.
And then there was just some of the drunkest fucking animals I've ever been a
that I've been in front of in a while.
I'm talking like literally screaming and whistling during setups.
Like I wasn't even saying anything and I just be like,
well you know I've been doing standup for a while and something in the back of
his neck,
this fucking whistle and about what,
I don't know.
I felt like I was doing like a rock concert.
You know like when you listen to a live album and they'll end the song and one
of those mumble and jackass singer songwriters and be like,
you know,
we've been coming out here for a while and he'll,
he'll,
yeah.
It's like,
dude,
he hasn't said anything.
He's on his way to the point and people are already screaming cause they're
fucking wasted.
So my apologies to the sober people who are at that show.
That show was fucking,
I'll be honest with you man.
That one was a lot of work with all those screaming and he was like 20 people
and they were in all different parts of the,
uh,
the venue and they were screaming and yelling and I finally snapped in the end.
And uh,
I dunno,
and I said a word I shouldn't have said,
you know what I mean?
And it's something the crowd like related to it.
And then it came up to me and they fucking gave me the tickets back and like,
who are you spending all this money?
You only would just,
and then through through the whole fucking tragedy of their life,
put it on me.
I didn't know what the fuck they were talking about,
you know?
And it's just one of those fucking things.
Once again,
it's like,
dude,
I talked about plane crashes,
I talked about sinking cruise ships.
I made fun of Bruce Gender,
so gender Bruce Jenner.
So I mean,
they just laughed at me.
So I mean technically it wasn't all of that offensive now was just the fucking
thing that,
that,
that was,
that was about your fucking life.
And not only that,
I just said a word.
I didn't even do a bit on it.
I basically said to the guy in the crowd,
I said,
Dick,
that guy was such a fucking moron.
I have 90 minutes to this guy.
If I snap.
I was like,
dude,
are you fucking retarded?
I never say that word.
And that night I happened to say in a moment of fucking ain't now obviously I'm
not making fun of fucking uh,
um,
whatever the fuck you supposed to say.
Mentally challenged people.
Why would ever do that?
And I've said in the past I didn't see these fucking people come up to me.
He showed the pervs you don't do the fucking,
show me a picture of their kid and just put the whole fucking thing on me.
And I wanna apologize to the next 40 people in line because I was processing
what the fuck just happened.
And then I got livid
the way they fucking handed me the tickets back.
And I took them because I didn't know what they are saying.
Like,
Hey,
throw these things out.
You're a piece of shit.
And you know,
it's like,
it's like who,
if they're listening 100% I apologize and 100% go fuck yourself.
Let me guess.
You never said anything fucked up,
right.
You never laughed at something you shouldn't have said.
You never lost your temper and fucking said something.
If you don't dump your whole fucking life on me like that,
like I'm the worst fucking person ever.
You know you are out of line.
And not only that,
once I realized what the fuck you were talking about,
I said,
oh my God,
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry that guy was yelling,
I shouldn't said it,
blah blah.
And you just wouldn't accept it.
You wouldn't fucking accept it.
Yeah.
Had to have your moment so you know my apologies and fuck you.
So that was that night
anyways.
You know what I mean?
Let me do it.
Some fucked up shit happen to me when I was a kid that I will not get into,
but I've seen comic's joke about it.
I don't give a fuck.
I know they're not attacking me.
I know they don't.
They don't wish that misery on me.
Jesus fly.
I'm going to comedy show,
right?
It's Christ.
Every fucking week.
You guys call me a ginger?
12 ways to Sunday.
I don't give a fuck.
Do I think you'll really hate me if you hated me?
You wouldn't be writing in.
I get it.
You fucking around.
Yeah.
Sorry.
I had to get that out.
I was something I wasn't going to talk about,
but if they didn't talk about it,
be fucking flicking me in the back of my year for the rest of this podcast.
So anyways,
oh my God.
I was only going like,
you know what?
I'm never going out after a fucking show again.
That's how fucking awful.
That whole goddamn moment was.
All right.
I probably,
this is why I probably should've talked about that.
Cause now I'm fucking,
I dunno,
I wish I didn't say it.
Why the fuck did they have to come that night?
You know,
what are the fucking odds?
Why did that drunk have to be there?
You know,
if I just ended the show five minutes before,
I wouldn't have said he's just fucking kills you.
You know,
people,
just,
Abby,
everybody's got a fucking moment now.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
dude,
I'm fucking driving through this country.
Right,
and you just seen all the water out in California.
It is that it brutally low levels and you know,
old Tony Monsanto there,
I'll be the fuck you say Tony's fucking with the food.
None of these cunts running for president are going to talk about any of that.
It's all going to be like the level with which people are freaking out that gay
people can now get get married.
Who gives a fuck,
who aren't like,
I don't understand people trying to protect,
you know,
what do they call it,
the sanctity of marriage or whatever these fucking morons that talking about.
It's like,
dude,
I don't know if you've noticed like 60% of them go down the shitter anyways.
You know what I mean?
Maybe these gay people be better at it than straight people in there.
They'll,
they'll up the numbers,
right?
Oh,
those poor bastards.
Gay People.
God bless you.
But I don't think that you realize what you fucking walked into.
We want to do it to Jesus Christ.
You know what,
being married is like.
Being married is like going on a ride at six flags.
You know what I mean?
It's fun,
it's fucking exciting.
But there's like a thesis fucking chance that one of the bolts is going to come
off and you're going to go flying into the woods.
If I ever told you guys about that,
I don't go to,
I don't go to amusement parks.
I absolutely refuse.
You know,
maybe you know Disney land I would go to,
I've gone to that.
But even then you go on space mountain,
you're like,
how fucking old is this ride?
You know what I mean?
Just there's always something going on.
But you know,
I feel like the stationary ones are safer because you know where they're at.
Those ones where they pick it up and put it down and then leave town,
you know,
you're still flow.
You flew into the bushes and the guy let's wrap it up and they get the fuck out
of there.
Um,
plus the wear and tear of putting them together and taking them down and
everything.
Ah Man,
why the fuck did that happen and show that fucking just,
it was a,
well,
that's the worst moment I've had as a comedian a long fucking time.
Cause I,
I felt I really hurt those people and I didn't want to do that.
But then to the way they fucking,
you know,
ah,
just writing my dis the whole fucking thing.
And then it wasn't until I just wished in the moment it could have said that.
So like plane or,
okay,
you're all right with that cruise ships.
You're okay.
Cruise ships sinking,
that's fine.
You know what I mean?
May tease and fucking Caitlyn Jenner.
That's fine.
That's not that all of that's funny.
Right?
Oh,
I wish I had it.
I was,
you had a fucking video tape of them sitting in the crowd laughing at all of
that shit and that fucking moron.
That's what I should've called them.
That was the thing.
I wasn't even thinking about,
like,
you know,
mentally challenged kids when I said that,
I was basically just saying,
hey,
why are you being such a fucking cunt?
Right.
And then some feminists will come up to me.
Um,
I have one of those and it's called a vagina and fucking sticks to catch him
tickets back in my face.
Sorry.
Enlightened the fuck up.
How about that?
If you're going to go to a comedy show,
if not,
you know,
stay the fuck home.
Go Watch lifetime.
Um,
anyways,
I'm going to keep going back to that.
I don't give a shit until I get it out of my fucking system.
So,
oh,
Billy cardio went off the rails the last two days.
I stayed out late.
Um,
you know,
so people that I work with,
uh,
showed up when I was in Vegas.
Surprise me.
They're like,
oh,
let's go out and get a cigar.
So I was like,
all right.
So we went out and,
uh,
stayed out till like five in the morning.
And in the meantime,
my,
uh,
my iPhone four s finally shit the bed,
you know,
Barnack was,
he had the forest and he finally switched to the sixth.
He was saying,
he goes,
dude,
once that battery starts cutting out,
you know,
it's going to get worse and worse and worse and finally fucking cut out.
And I plugged it in and I was getting nothing.
So,
you know,
the lovely knee is like,
well,
we gotta get you a new phone.
So,
uh,
I went into Caesars,
Caesars palace next door where a,
they'd have all these beautiful shops and everything and all these fucking
animals walking in and out of them,
like make,
you know,
shuffling around a fucking sweatpants.
So some guy,
and there was like true religion pants and a tee shirt,
did not see any ed hardy shirts.
Ed Hardy shirts are gone.
I dunno what ocean they're floating in right now.
I'm guessing the Indian Ocean for some fucking reason,
we can't dump it all in the Pacific.
Right.
I don't know where those fucking things are.
Um,
but I guarantee you when they do the,
uh,
the fast times at Ridgemont high or some shit or the dazed and confused of this
error,
they're going to have people wearing those true religion jeans,
or maybe last decade,
I should say,
in the Ed hardy shirts telling you,
dude,
that's why George Carlin,
another reason why George Carlin was a genius,
you know,
is if you notice most of his specials,
he wore just all black.
I mean,
that's never going out of fucking style.
You know,
he probably figured that out after he had his hippy dippy shit that he wore in
the 70s.
You know what I mean?
Some of that stuff.
And he started looking at it like,
oh my God,
do I get flowers at my jeans?
Why did I think that was cool?
Because everybody else did.
But they got rid of theirs and there's theirs videotape of you with yours on.
So you look like the only asshole at warm,
you know?
So
anyways,
uh,
I'm all over the fucking map here.
So,
uh,
dude,
Bakersfield was tremendous.
Um,
trying to work my way back to think where the hell we were.
Oh,
I already talked about,
I keep forgetting that I do the Thursday podcast.
So you already heard about that.
Uh,
playing the Fox theater and all of that.
And obviously if Britain,
no Britain will grill forward.
We're fucking wrong.
You can open your [inaudible] will know bootcamp bureau.
Um,
did that one.
And uh,
then we did two nights at the Mirage and uh,
just had a fucking amazing time and um,
tremendous crowds and a,
so tonight's the last one down here in Tucson,
Arizona,
and it was like a seven hour drive down here.
We've got up at like 9:00 AM or something like that.
Drove all the way down here and I gotta get you gotta drive out to a venue or at
like six 45.
So I'm gonna try and get to as much.
Maybe I'll do 45 minutes.
Who knows?
Last 15,
you guys were all like,
Bill,
cut it off now.
Get Shit faced and then do the rest of the podcast.
Um,
okay.
So anyways,
uh,
oh,
here's something,
you know,
it's a fucking pet peeve of mine and fucking,
uh,
I don't know if this is just
okay
about women or if it's casino women.
I have no idea.
Yeah.
But women who,
uh,
at the end of the night take off the high heels because their feet hurt and they
just start walking down the street and their bare feet or walking across the
casino rug and their bare feet,
you know,
bottom of their feet all fucking dirty.
I was joking about that at the Mirage.
I was like,
you know what?
You can't,
you can't marry that.
You can't marry that dude.
That's a quitter.
You know,
you,
you couldn't make it till the last fucking 1500 yards up to your room.
You couldn't throw a pair of little flippy flops into your clutch or something
like that.
What kind of a fucking animal?
Okay.
You know,
I could only imagine.
I know what women think.
Well,
if you had to walk around and those,
yeah.
You know,
I'd have some flip flops.
I would,
there's no fucking way I would ever walk barefoot across the rough.
People walk in and out of the fucking men's and ladies' room with God knows,
you know what the fuck goes on in there?
Literally I shit shell a shit and piss show goes on in there.
All kinds of bacteria and you're just walking barefoot through it like you're
Christ.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
You fucking girlfriends got to wash your feet when you come in.
It just,
it just,
it's that to me,
that takes a fucking 10 all the way down to about it.
Well,
if we're just talking sex,
who's kidding who?
A nine and a half.
But if we're talking about the mother of your children,
it's just,
it's done.
It's a done fucking deal.
If she is an adult,
if her feet are going to be that dirty,
how filter your fucking kids fee's going to be?
Yeah.
You want to jump in on it?
Grab a microphone.
Um,
no,
like late at night that night we stayed out a Friday night and we ended up at
the,
uh,
the Deli there trying to grab me a microphone here.
Would that be in my bag?
Uh,
Christ,
I don't know where it is.
My backpack.
Yes.
My pack that I put on my back.
Yeah.
Aka My backpack.
Um,
yeah,
me and Jay ended up in this,
they got like this Carnegie Deli or Carnegie,
depending if you're from the east coast or the Midwest.
I've noticed that in Pittsburgh.
It's always Carnegie East Coast.
It's Carnegie.
Oh,
traveling.
Um,
so we were there and these two girls got into this who didn't have shoes on,
kind of gotten to this drunk and like sort of have a little fucking play fight.
So one of them kind of falls down and her legs go up in the air,
like right up over the booth.
And I was standing there waiting to order and I just saw her,
the filthy soles of her feet.
And uh,
it just,
I,
I can't say it made me lose my appetite at all.
I'm just,
I'm just babbling here cause you know what I'm doing.
I'm trying to find the other fucking microphone.
I know Brian and you know we brought it,
cause you brought it in for you.
There it is.
Nope.
All right,
so it's down here.
Here it is.
Ah,
there it is.
[inaudible] is this an entertaining podcast?
This podcast is now been renamed to people looking for a microphone.
Yeah.
So Ne when we finally get this hooked up ever Deli,
you're going to weigh in on this.
I want to wait.
Yeah,
you want to weigh in on it?
Do you want to have your 2 cents?
Yes,
please.
Hey,
it's Donald Trump and knocked out of the ratio.
I'm really rooting that he stays in the longest,
so,
so he can just be continued to be the most entertaining person on it cause
everybody else is going to go out.
Sure.
Ha ha ha ha.
Oh Andrew.
Okay,
Sean,
we got,
uh,
we got to do things.
Oh yeah.
Hang on one second.
Let's see what we got here.
All right.
Check,
check,
check.
Two,
two,
check.
All right,
so what,
what are your feelings?
No,
I want it.
Yeah.
Talking about the,
uh,
dirty,
dirty feet bitches.
Yeah.
Here's the thing.
I,
I agree with you.
DB BS.
If you can feel your heels,
you don't need to be wearing them.
That's really the bottom line and I know you want to look cute.
I want to look you.
I want to wear hi sexy,
gorgeous heels.
They make my legs and ask amazing.
Want to be looking cute,
but if you can't handle it,
you need to not wear them.
You need to save your highest sexiest,
but most like God damn looking shoes that shows off your pedicure when you have
a date or whatever,
when you're getting picked up and you go in the car,
in the restaurant,
back in the car,
back to the crib,
otherwise you don't need to be wearing.
If you're going out dancing,
you need to find some cute shoes that are a lower heel that you can dance in and
you can walk in.
We don't look crazy because I can't stand that either.
Whenever I see a woman walking around with their bare feet,
I want to scream at them like,
don't just don't do anything.
You know what?
Don't do it.
And also save your feet.
Be Smart.
It's not worth it.
It's really not worth it.
Looking like,
what's the word I wanna use a trashy mess tracing through the casino with no
shoes on.
You know what else is great?
And that was one.
They take the shoes off and that just now they look like this little stumpy
person in the short dress and the illusion of all the other women.
You're like,
oh my God,
look how along those legs are you really start doing the math.
You start knocking off a few inches.
I have shoes that I wear if I'm going to a con.
Well see the thing is I feel like if I go to a concert,
I'm not doing that standing room shit cause I'm too old for it anyway.
But I have,
shoot,
if I'm going out and I'm going to get a copy and I say that I'm not,
I wouldn't marry someone that takes their shoes off.
That's a lock.
The door test.
That's
the lock the door.
You are you talking about the car door thing from a Bronx tale.
One of your girlfriends are,
they take the shoes off.
People know dirt.
You don't do it.
Do you have any old dirty finger in your crew now?
I don't have any dirty feet bitches in my career.
I keep them on.
Or you don't wear them seriously though.
Oh,
there you go.
So why the hell would you fucking marry that and have a kid?
Well,
I don't know.
He needs to make the leap from you.
Take off your shoes to equals.
I'm not going to marry you.
That's,
that's a bit of a,
that's a bit of a stretch on breathable.
Unbreakable.
Yeah,
you're done.
I'm not,
I might,
I might have to add that into the fucking act.
As far as like the people that,
you know,
when I,
when I'm doing my cleanse of the population,
so the water supply stays where it needs to be.
Oh,
that would be another person I would get rid of women who take their shoes off
when the final 10% of the night or content to walk down a public fucking street.
Also when their bare feet,
why don't you put in inserts,
installs into your shoes?
I have insoles and all of my heels,
they get the clear ones.
The doctor Scholl's I know you feel like an old lady going into that section,
but I have them in every single pair of heels because,
and even still,
they hurt my fucking feet.
Tom.
Neil,
why would they go out and something you're asking them,
why don't they do something smart?
Yeah.
Well maybe Tom who kind of fucking proud.
I don't give a shit.
If I was wearing snow shoes when we went to no fucking way,
I wouldn't,
I would,
I would take those off and walked barefoot across the casino once the Michael
Jackson.
So those shoes that I was weighing,
gorgeous,
amazing,
hurt my seem like a bit expensive.
I put the insulin OIM unnecessary will hurt and I stuck it out.
I stuck at fucking now cause I had committed myself to wearing them and I wasn't
going to quit and I wasn't going to look like one of those girls because that's
messy.
Sloppy.
You don't want to look like that pop up,
up,
up.
Yeah.
I rocky that shit.
Boom.
Nini,
boom.
Yeah.
Let's take it,
deal with it.
And if you can't hang then down.
By the way,
Michael Jackson show was amazing.
Amazing.
Even with the school we do kids.
That was weird.
I it was for the kids,
but I don't want to ruin the show.
But at one point I challenge any person to go to that show.
And at some point you're not.
They could just put on the fucking hat.
Just put on the fucking hat.
I that musical theater low eve.
I get it.
That hat has power.
Put it on.
And who your fucking dance already?
Jesus Christ.
It's a Cirque du Soleil show.
It's called one.
It's tremendous.
Please go see this show and I challenge you not to.
Time magazine says,
all right,
I'm going to talk about lacking that.
Cried.
I want to talk about hockey.
Oh,
so this is the part where I dip out,
right?
And this is part where I,
so thank you for not being a dirty feet,
bitch.
I love you too.
Fucking animals.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
oh,
let's Talk Nhl hockey here.
Jesus Christ,
the Bruins are,
are,
are going through a whole fucking rebuild here.
I,
you know,
what are the only reason why Douggie Hamilton getting traded did not shock me
was because the first half of this tour I,
I was,
I was working with Joe Barton.
Nick,
who knows as much about hockey,
is anybody on the NHL Channel and he was saying like,
uh,
okay.
He was just doing his bart nick thing,
just saying like they should get rid of Doug Hamilton.
He's too much of a hit on the cap.
You want to keep McQuaid.
He's a stay at home guy on defense.
He sticks up for his teammate.
Every team in the NHL is looking for a guy like Adam McQuaid.
That's the guy you keep,
Doug,
he's too soft,
blah,
blah.
And I was just sitting the guy,
I like him,
he's kind of offensive,
but everything that he fucking said and the guy gets shipped off to
Calgary,
I still loved them,
but I never saw them trading Luci.
I mean I,
that guy,
he,
he's the fucking locomotive.
He's the toughest guy in our fucking team,
and now he's gone.
Okay.
Like,
come on
Cheech going down,
crashing the fucking net.
Who's going to do that now?
You know,
putting Ryan Miller and his place.
Who's going to do that now?
Sorry.
Buffalo fans.
I'm fucking with you.
I know he got frustrated because he thought he had a breakaway and it bounced
over his stick.
So he acted a little child.
Is there,
who's going to stab someone in the balls when we need them to?
Sorry,
I'm actually bringing up his worst thing.
Other than that.
Yeah,
he's a fucking force.
So now he goes to the kinks and to me,
once again,
the West is way more fucking interesting than the east.
How will Chicago respond?
Yeah,
to that force of nature.
That is Milan Lucita cheats.
That's now at the kings.
The only thing I liked about the trade is I live in La.
So it's yet another reason to go see that great team,
even though they didn't make the playoffs last year.
So,
um,
all I will say about this is I hope the Bruins,
no,
it that doing,
it's the exact same thing I said about the patriots a couple of years ago when
they stayed,
they did it know,
I can't remember who the fuck they traded and I was just like,
I hope they know what they're doing.
And uh,
evidently they did because we just won a Superbowl.
So,
um,
you know,
at the end of the day when I'm a fucking comedian,
what do I know about building a Goddamn team?
I'll tell you right now,
I didn't like us getting rid of our GM.
The guy obviously did a great fucking job.
We won a Stanley Cup.
He makes one stupid comment and everybody listens to Dan Shaughnessy who doesn't
watch hockey on any level.
I don't give a shit.
They need to make a move.
Does Dan Shaughnessy even write articles anymore to see?
Just take like fucking old articles he's already written a thousand times and
just pull fucking words out and put new new players names in there.
I riff on that guy too much.
You know what I mean?
I rip on it too much,
but the only time it really bugs me is when he fucking
is,
when he,
when he trashes the Bruins,
it's like,
dude,
you don't even know what the fuck you talking.
I mean,
he want you to God damn splinter ring.
So just shut up.
Anyways.
Um,
oh dude.
So we pull in here to a Tucson,
Tucson,
Arizona,
and uh,
we're driving down the street.
We're a little bit lost and we get into this shit part of fucking town,
you know?
And we're driving down the street and this fucking white trash looking dude
walking up the street just gives the finger to the buses.
We drive by
low.
Let's go and you see that guy?
He's given us the finger.
What's it giving us the finger for?
It's like Jesus,
Jay,
do the math.
Look at the neighborhood.
What do you think?
Fuck you.
Fix it up and,
and he's blaming his whole fucking life on us rather than whatever.
Guide them into that situation.
Be it racism or whatever.
Why Not Racism?
He's white.
I don't know what the fuck it was,
but it wasn't a bus fucking bus.
Um,
I'm not going to lie to you.
Made me really uncomfortable.
I was like,
oh,
should we be driving through here in this thing?
Maybe we should take I fucking taxi.
Um,
anyway,
so,
uh,
so here we are.
We've got one,
like,
I read some of this fucking advertising.
Was it six 15?
It's one of the great things about being a guy.
He take a shower and like fucking three minutes shake off like a Goddamn Hound,
right?
Poor women got to go in there,
you know,
putting on all like clown makeup,
put on their shoes.
I'm going to make it a feet fucking cart.
You know,
it's a lot of advantages.
All right,
here we go.
Hey,
we go.
All right,
Hulu,
everybody for the first time ever,
you can now stream the entire Seinfeld series,
arguably the greatest sitcom of all time,
exclusively on Hulu.
That's every episode,
all nine seasons,
all streaming on Hulu for seven 99 a month.
Visit hulu.com and sign up to get access to all of your favorite Seinfeld
episodes again for seven 99 a month.
You can watch all nine seasons of Seinfeld with your Hulu subscription.
Um,
speaking
of that,
I was actually watching some,
uh,
comedians in cars getting coffee and watched,
the Jay Leno one,
which you knew it was going to be great because he knows all about cars and heat
and then what was called tool.
It was also like stand up history when you know that guy came up like when there
weren't comedy clubs.
So he,
you're not going to beat that guy when it comes to like hell gigs.
Like I went on after like strippers and shit.
So he was talking about working the playboy club and how this guy would sit
there and watch you and grade your act and then send the report card to Hugh
Hefner.
I mean,
who knows if he actually did it,
but he put the fear of God in you.
And then he had a story about doing a private Gig,
some Sinatra Gig,
and there was a real life famous gangster in the crowd and uh,
it was just like,
Jesus,
this guy caught the tail end of the Goodfella years.
So it's a real,
I highly recommend that one.
Um,
I know I watched like three of them to Jason Alexander.
One was cool and uh,
all the Howard stern one was great.
The Howard Stern one was great.
Um,
so anyways,
so that's his other show.
So you gotta watch this and Seinfeld was also nice enough to have me on the
show,
which was an unbelievable honor.
So he wanted to do the podcast to solid a checkout the Seinfeld series on Hulu.
Okay.
Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody,
uh,
some of you out there who still haven't joined dollar shave club,
what's the issue?
People once the deal,
these guys are awesome.
Seriously.
And you've heard me talking about them for years now.
Their razors really are amazing.
It's more convenient and cost a fraction of the price if you still not getting
it.
Here's how the club works.
Go to dollar shave club.com and pick one of their three great raisers.
This six blade executive for the fucking Mediterraneans or the Werewolf fucking
human being.
You've got to shave your back.
Get the God damn six blade executive and get a close friend that can deal with
driving that thing.
Write down your back to the crack of your ass.
Um,
the four blade for x and the two blade humble twin.
you get your first box in about a week.
It includes a free handle and a sleeve of blade cartridges.
It's high quality stuff.
Got that weight to it.
Everybody,
like the expensive ones you've used before.
The humble twin has to stainless steel blades and an aloe strip.
It's all unique.
You've never gotten a shave like this.
After that first box.
They mail you a sleeve of replacement blades every month or every other,
however you want to do it.
You never have to worry about it again.
That's it.
If you haven't joined yet,
you're missing out.
Simple as that.
You're out of your mind.
If you don't do this,
try dollar shave club.com/burr that's dollar shave club.com/burr.
All right.
Um,
how many more of these,
oh,
there's only one more.
Let's mercifully get through my live reads here.
Legal Zone.
There are a lot of great reasons.
Smart businesses.
See there's a lot of great ways in smart business people trust zoom for status.
If you want to incorporate form an LLC or nonprofit,
file a patent or trademark,
get a DBA in more legal zoom provides to help you need over the past decade,
more than a million business owners.
Just like you have started with legal zoom.
But did you know that legal zoom is also your first stop when you need advice
from any attorney from an attorney,
I should say,
legal zooms,
not a law firms.
So they built a network of independent attorneys in most states to provide legal
advice and other useful services to help you run your business.
So whether you need a contract reviewed or advice on whether you should
incorporate or form an LLC,
whatever your legal question is,
start with legal zoom.
And as always,
they provide complete transparency with upfront pricing,
customer views,
and 100% satisfaction guaranteed.
Uh,
make the smart choice for your business@legalzoom.com today.
And don't forget to enter bur bur the checkout to save even more.
Again,
that's bar at checkout for more savings,
legalzoom,
Promo code,
burr legal help is here.
And as always,
if you want to donate to the podcast,
anytime you're going to Amazon,
go to [inaudible] dot com click on the merchant page,
click on the,
uh,
the little fucking Amazon do Hickey.
Whatever you call it,
takes you to Amazon.
I get credit for it.
Doesn't cost you any money whatsoever.
And they kicked me a little bit of cash for fucking driving traffic there.
And then I give it,
give some of it,
I should say a portion of the proceeds.
You know,
I try to give to a fucking charity and then I say what the charity is.
And I do that for six months and everybody tells me it's a scam.
And then I try to find another one.
So right now I do it for St Jude as far as I can tell,
they're on the up and up.
All right,
so there you go.
Ah,
that's 31 minutes.
31 minutes in.
All right,
so right now I'm going to hit pause and I'm going to go,
fuck that.
I can keep going here,
right?
Can I keep going?
No,
I should get off.
Ah,
she's saying to get off the horn.
Wait a minute.
Oh my God.
This is fucking maniac.
Jesus Christ.
You know,
do people know how to be in a fucking show?
Certain people you hook up the fucking cool other people you'll hook up and then
I'm here.
Now I'm here.
Oh No,
I'm calling your phone.
Is Everything gonna be okay?
Relax.
Okay.
Tickets going to be there.
You're going to sit there,
right?
Your wife's going to take off your shoes.
Get a feed all dirty.
You're gonna slam a couple of fucking scotches and I'm going to get up there and
do a little fucking clown dance for you.
All right.
It's fucking an hour and 40 minutes before the show.
I still,
I haven't even put my red nose on yet.
Oh,
I was all Billy sport coats Saturday night in Vegas.
Came out there with a pocket square and everything and I actually stuck it out
and I wore that jacket for the whole show.
Oh my God.
This motherfucker.
Um,
and I wore the jacket for whole show even though it was starting to get hot.
The only,
actually,
the only real reason why I didn't take it off was because I had a white shirt
underneath it and I'm pasty as fuck.
And uh,
you know,
I didn't want to,
I want to be up there looking like a head on top of a fucking candle stick.
Um,
so anyways,
oh by the way,
if you just end to working out,
you know that Michael Jackson show those Cirque du Solei people are fucking
unbelievable.
This one guy,
he does a routine on this rope,
climbing this rope up and down the fucking thing,
80 80 fucking different ways for a whole song.
If you can go up a climb rope,
climbing rock,
climbing up a climbing rope and come back down using your feet,
you know,
that's impressive.
If you could do it without using your feet,
that's even more impressive.
But what this guy was doing was just on a whole other level.
And then the biggest beast of the show was this one woman who came out and was
basically,
uh,
one of the strongest human beings I've ever seen in my life.
She was doing stuff that just defied
even some of the stuff,
like I've seen that,
um,
like you ever see those guys like,
dude,
like the human flag,
and then they'll do like this.
This woman did all of that and she would do it.
So for like five minute chunks,
she did,
she didn't do it.
And that's how you do the human flag.
And then that's it.
She'd be in that position for like 20 seconds and then go into something even
harder.
I remember her for finishing fucking move.
She's upside down on,
on,
you know,
I guess it's called a Stripper Pole,
you know?
But what she did was so artistic.
We'll just say it was like a street sign,
Paul,
just to give her some class there.
Um,
Paul Dancing.
All right.
There you go.
Whatever.
So she fucking was upside down in a full split with no hands.
Does that thing with you just sort of let yourself slide down the pole and then
you stop yourself when people do that with their hands.
That's amazing.
She did it upside down in a split and she did it with their legs and a smile on
her face that never betrayed any sort of pain.
It was the greatest display of a,
I dunno,
she was unbelievable.
She was unfucking believable pick.
Oh,
I can't say what I was just going to say.
I would say pictures so and so in a bikini,
but now that would've been bad.
Um,
anyways.
All right.
That's it for silver bill.
Hang in there and through the magic of editing,
I will be back in about two seconds and I'll be a little bit happier.
Maybe a little more horse than the voice and definitely a lot more.
Uh,
well I'm not buzzed at all right now.
I'll have a couple of fucking,
I'll throw down a couple of whatever.
Alright.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I've talked to in a minute.
Ah,
right.
Bagged a magical mystery tour.
His cubby to take you a wedding one.
It's in my fucking head and now I'm not drunk.
I've had two bud lights,
you know,
I might as well had some reason Brent.
It's such a weak fucking beer.
Um,
all right.
So I did the last show and a great crowd and all that type of shit.
They had a wonderful time in this conference room and a thank you to everybody
who came out to the shows and everybody came out to the tour.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
and I would leave it at that cause a,
yeah.
Yeah.
How do I not say it?
I can't,
he was there,
you know,
they were having a,
yeah,
they were having one of those days down there.
I can't say it.
Yeah,
I a wait,
what are you going to fucking do?
I don't,
you know,
that's not the way you go about it.
I sit there and I act like everything was fine.
No,
no,
no.
You're not jumping on this talking that shit.
I'm not going to talk shit.
Yeah,
you are.
No,
no,
I'm not.
I'm not doing it.
Shush.
The man has spoken and he said,
woman,
Shush.
Oh,
Geez.
All right,
let's get into the fucking questions here.
All right.
Oh,
class ain't,
yeah.
Yeah.
You know what?
I'm going to send one of those days.
You know,
it's still one of those things.
That's why everything's all fucked up.
All right.
Jack Williams.
Jack Williams,
Billy Lansdowne street.
Not sure if you heard this.
Yeah,
right down near family.
Back in the day.
You wouldn't go down there at night.
Now you can skip down the street.
You can law.
I love Lansdowne Street.
It's a hang out there during college.
Alright.
Wbz for Boston news anchor.
Jack Williams retired this week.
Wow.
I,
you know,
I'm afraid to see how old he is.
That's going to make me feel even fucking older than okay.
Can you please give a short speech about him as though you were at his
retirement party
that is retire parties.
I'd be half in the bag.
Yeah.
Why?
Say something can wake up people.
Jack Williams fucking Jack.
I love you man.
We'll bold red heads in this business.
I used to watch you when I was a kid and you were 40 itself.
You will his walker.
I had a great rapport.
You always had a great sense of humor and that stuff you did for the kids.
Wednesday's child,
the gaze.
Just,
I love that guy.
I can't believe he's retired.
That guy.
I mean,
I'm not an athlete.
Comes to retirement party.
That guy was the best,
is the best total professional.
And he was funny as hell.
He had a great sense of humor.
Um,
then the bed,
I used to watch some way back in the day,
it was Jack Williams,
Liz Walker and Bob Lubell did the sports and that was it.
And then they throw it to Bob knew I knew me.
They throw it to him.
And that poor bastard.
I remember when we used to go to Patriots Games,
he did this thing when here,
for some stupid reason they thought this would be a good idea and this is back.
They've sent him to,
to Sullivan Stadium.
It might even have been Shaefer stadium back then.
They wanted to do this thing whenever the Patriots were right down on the goal
line,
they would record him,
you know,
for the segments later on in the news for him to be like,
and you know,
whatever,
three 28 in the third quarter the Patriots were down on the one yard line and
then they would just,
he would turn around and,
and then if they scored he'd say,
and Tony Collins ran the ball in blah blah,
blah,
blah blah.
So he fucking would go down there and we're all hammered and he'd be taken a
knee and we just wait for his lips to start moving and we'd all just start
screaming,
fucking no may,
no,
he'd beat down on one knee.
I remember at one point he was looking like it was get upset and then he just
saw,
just put the mic down like you had it in his hand.
But he just let it go down like that.
And he just shook his head and started laughing.
It's just like,
why would you do that to the guy?
So anyways,
um,
all three of them,
they were funny as hell.
Bob Knew Myra was great too.
It now does all the horse race and everything.
So I now that Boston legend retires,
Jack Williams,
thank you for all your great news class and uh,
the Wednesday's child and all of that stuff.
You awesome.
So there you go.
I hope other people gave a fuck about that.
Who weren't from Boston.
All right.
Advice for my daughter,
uh,
top of the morning to you.
Standard redhead joke that everybody's done and I'm zillion time.
All right,
I want to thank you in advance for any advice you have for me or my daughter.
My daughter is third.
I'm gonna say it the whole way through is 13 and doesn't have many interests.
At least none that she is willing to stick with.
Well she's only 13 to the fuck.
She's got to pick a career.
You screaming at her every night.
Is it going to be finance?
You're going to be a nurse.
However,
there seems to be one subject that keeps cup coming up,
uh,
that she asks,
my help with.
And that's comedy.
She's a funny and incredibly sarcastic kid.
My favorite type of humor,
which she probably got it from you then.
I was about to say,
yeah.
Oh cause she's daddy's little sarcastic girl and she wants,
it's her learn how to write jokes.
I have searched for classes,
but they appear to be given at a comedy club and I don't think they would want a
13 year old girl around.
You wouldn't want to bring a 13 year old girl now a comedy club.
They've got half a person,
like a sale.
They've got to have some kids programs,
don't they do that?
Let me finish.
Before you come in here with your wisdom,
can you recommend any kind of book or video class that she could study?
I've seen a lot of material,
but I'm not sure what will help her get started.
Big Fan and appreciate any suggestions that you may have.
And if you read this on the advice show,
please give me a heads up.
I will have her.
How the fuck would I give you?
I don't know who you are.
What is the advice show?
Oh,
let her hear it directly from you and not shittily passed along from her.
More on father.
And I would like to count how many mistakes you made reading this letter.
I kept,
well you want to talk about mistakes too.
When you said at least none that she's willing,
you spelt none non.
All right,
fuck.
Oh,
I kept the word small for your illiterate ginger ass.
It's such arrogant.
Cons.
Maybe this is why your daughter doesn't mind to share interest because you're
kind of a prey.
Oh He's,
you know what it is.
He's worried that I'm going to shit on him so he's going to shit on me first.
So anyways,
uh,
first of all,
Emerson College,
all of a sudden now you can major in comedy.
I heard that tonight.
Yeah.
Which kind of makes sense and soldering,
uh,
the tickets,
the comedic,
the legends that have graduated from the school.
Oh,
just such as bill burr.
Just the tickets that comics are selling.
When I started out there was a handful of people playing theaters and that would
be like George Carlin,
Bill Cosby.
Uh,
see I'm already forgetting.
I mean maybe those guys that had their teeth,
TV shows am I started,
Seinfeld still hadn't become a hit yet,
so he was probably just selling out clubs.
Maybe Roseanne Barr if she gave a fuck enough at that point.
Cause Roseanne was still going.
But there was a,
I mean it was a short,
short,
short list.
And now there's like a zillion people out there,
it seems they're all playing in theaters.
They're all right.
New Hours and everything.
Like I,
there's never been a more prolific time.
So I think they're finally seeing it when like how many fucking comics have sold
out Madison Square Garden.
Like that was like,
it was like Eddie Murphy did it,
dice clay did it,
and then Dane Cook did it.
So there was like a fucking,
it was two guys in the 80s.
Nobody in the 90s that I knew of,
no comic in the 90s that I know of,
that that wasn't what Eddie had already stopped dice maybe did it in 1990 but
uh,
yeah,
he was doing the show.
MMM.
That was when a lot of Yak comments were out doing their own TV shows.
Tim Allen.
Yeah.
I don't know how it happened.
And all of a sudden now,
you know,
there's like,
like I think I know like five people that sold the fucking thing out.
So in mine it's now a,
it's full.
It's finally,
I think just comedy.
Well maybe that they're having as like comedy writing in that,
but I always look at it as like being a comedian.
It's actually a a,
it's a career now where people used to kind of look at it even though I'd always
was a career,
but it was always kind of viewed as like it was this stepping stone to get a
Sitcom I find is Shane's that major in comedy.
It's cool but it's like it's such a weird thing.
So there probably is weird.
Do you have to be funny and like your application and shit?
Like they probably do like the acting program where you have to do some material
there.
Probably study all like the history of comedy from the very beginning,
like Vaudeville.
Up until now they watch a ton of specials.
They probably have to write it.
So I got kinda like when I did Emerson and I graduated with a media arts degree.
Right.
We watched a shitload of movies.
We wrote a lot of papers about it.
That's probably what they're going to do.
They have to do some sort of performance.
Right.
Well right now his question was what can you do now?
I would just want,
so what city are they?
Did they say what city they're in?
I don't know.
I would just say just watch as many comedians is as you can or watch as many
comedies as you can.
Uh,
it depends if you want to be a writer or something like that.
I mean,
these,
these are the fun years.
Like there's no,
like you're 13.
I mean,
it sounds like,
exactly.
It'll probably change.
It should be in Jordan.
No,
but it should be enjoyable.
It should be enjoyable.
Yeah.
Why are you trying to make it a career for her already knows he loves her?
No,
I know.
I'm just joking.
But also,
um,
they,
uh,
do improv classes for people that age.
That's a good fun thing to do.
Don't do,
don't take an Improv class at 13.
That's like teaching a kid how to throw a fucking curve ball.
We've been too young while if you try to teach a kid when he's too young to
throw a curve ball,
he neat.
Let me finish.
You get fucking interrupted me here.
They've fucking,
uh,
they,
they get the Tommy John Surgery now what?
Now you're going to pile it on me.
I'm not pouting.
There you are.
That's your pouch face.
Is this my pal?
Yeah.
I was trying to,
I had a nice fucking reference there about throwing the curve ball.
It was going well and you,
you would it in on me,
so I decided to defend myself and now you know what's going to happen.
You're going to fucking,
you're within three more dumb things and me saying of doing that thing where you
cross your arms and you fucking look in the other direction.
My was already half Christ.
I know and then I say what's wrong?
And you go,
nothing.
Nothing's wrong.
Something's wrong.
You got your fucking arms crossed.
I don't understand what her go into an Improv class is is why is that a bad
idea?
Because a lot of those improv theaters,
they also do comedy writing workshops and all that kind of stuff.
I'll tell you why,
because anybody in comedy and their job is to teach 13 year olds how to do
Improv.
He stinks.
He married a rich guy and they're fucking bored and now they,
oh,
maybe this is my talent and they're going to teach him more shit.
I had this is,
this is what you do.
Not when I was 13 when you were 13 that this is what you do.
Hang out with your friends and joke around and be funny and,
and find out the movies that,
you know,
make your generation left.
Just do that and just this,
this is the,
it should be fun.
Should be fun.
Yeah.
That's a good point.
And Be,
you know,
turn this into like the sports dad's worms,
which was the reference where they teach them how to throw a fucking curve ball
at 13 and the movement that you do when you throw it,
you're snapping your wrist like that.
The tendons and their arms are still growing or whatever.
I don't know what it is medically,
but they,
their arm is not strong enough to do it.
And these kids need Tommy John Surgery,
which is basically you take a ligament outta your fucking leg and replace it in
the elbow from,
they should be skipping rocks across the a fucking lake.
You know,
the advice that I gave?
No,
you're absolutely right.
The advice I gave,
Holy Shit can say that again.
What I have a recording.
Go ahead.
Oh,
when I heard that you're writing,
you said absolutely right.
I don't think I've ever heard the,
uh,
the advice I just gave is the kind of advise my,
my dad would give where he'd be like,
well,
get into a class and take this and do this writing thing.
And other than that,
he would make it this whole big sage payments.
Well,
there's a time and place for that and it's not when you're 13,
13.
Yeah.
He should be walking off from school if they didn't have your fucking believe in
as a pedophile.
Behind every fucking tree should be goofing off with your friends and,
and just,
you should know how to make people laugh.
He should just be fucking making people laugh.
You don't want to break it down and be like,
oh,
I just made my 13 year old friend left.
Well,
let's see.
Let's look at the setup and what was the punchline?
You're going to start doing it.
Oh,
here comes my,
you normally do today at school.
You know,
they do day in 13.
Oh,
we work am my miss directions.
Did you wouldn't believe it.
And I tagged this whole thing about the lunch lady.
You don't want to do that.
Just fucking have like all the fun out of it.
Exactly.
Just,
I would say,
watch the legends of today.
Like Melissa McCarthy,
Kristen Wiig,
whatever the fuck you're into.
And uh,
you know,
I dunno.
I Dunno what to tell you that,
that's what I would do.
I wouldn't mind.
Yeah,
I'm sticker in a fucking comedy class.
Whoa.
Jesus.
File that under old
comedy.
What is it?
Webster's Dick Syron shock as,
what is this thing that we call comedy?
All right.
Vetch.
Vegetarian Barbecue.
Okay.
Oh,
Billy boy.
The pipes,
the pipes are calling.
They go to something new.
Oh,
Billy boy.
I'll do justice to our pipes.
The pipes are quarreling.
Who's a song I was singing that you should keep watching the fucking repeats of
true detective Bra.
That
birds or the nose were
fucking phenomenal show.
I can't wait to see,
uh,
Vince and that go from the phone booth movies.
Oh my God.
You said the phone booth.
Wow.
You're this or the Sushi restaurant.
You're really reaching back into Colin ferals,
a imdv page with foam booth.
I don't see movies.
That's the last one I saw it and I just saw that to be like,
how did these cheap fox,
because they didn't want to hang with the guys standing in a phone booth is
times square or something like that.
So it wasn't cheap to shoot that.
I know.
And it was a phone booth and it was like 2003 and they didn't exist anymore.
Um,
I like your impression of that song,
the theme song from true detective to do it again,
cause I love it.
No,
I love the song too.
Until you watched every episode 500 times.
I'd be just walking around my house choir dusty.
Oh God.
She's watching another one that is the handsome family,
a husband and wife band who do that and music.
And they also do the theme to the new season and they're amazing.
And I loved their music now.
I love that Gothic.
He kind of comes a collectic.
Oh,
I am.
I'm so KCRW with it right now.
Sorry.
You sound like you're high right now.
I wish vegetarian barbecue or Billy boy the pipes,
the pipes are calling a last Sunday my girlfriend dragged me to a vegetarian
barbecue.
Full disclosure,
I was told that there would be grilled chicken skewers,
uh,
there,
but I didn't see a single one.
Sounds like something in silver lake.
And we got there on time.
Maybe that's how they learn or people over.
Exactly.
It's a vegetarian barbecue.
Terrible.
That's like,
hey,
let's go to this gay sex orgy.
I swear to God there's going to be some hetro action going on over there
and everybody's banging me in the ass.
And I was just like,
have I been duped here?
I really want a long way to make that point.
Sorry.
Um,
you have to bring your own food to shit like this.
Yeah.
All right.
Instead,
she should have brought the biggest fucking red is stake.
He could find
mix their dumb portobello mushrooms.
What's up pussies manage.
I know I'm going to die before you,
but I can look myself in the eye when I dope,
whatever dumb things.
Mediators,
not like I don't eat meat.
And not only that,
I'm not dumb,
but I like vegetables.
I didn't see a single one and the time,
blah,
blah blah.
Instead,
I only saw vegetables skewers,
grilled corn and a bowl of Orzo.
I don't even want to know what that is.
It's a grain.
It's like,
it's like Rice Pilaf.
That's what it tastes like.
Oh,
is that gonna be the new craze?
Orzo the new craze something JP side and wheat pita bread.
Not even regular Peter.
They couldn't even give me that.
I felt bad for the best.
There's nothing worse than somebody fucks with the food.
The only saving grace.
We're a key lime pie.
Okay.
And chips and dip and some decent beer.
That's pretty good.
That's pretty strong.
Uh,
I could maybe forgive the Veggie barbecue if the people holding it weren't the
most obnoxious hipsters as well.
They were both artists.
Shocker and painful to listen to as they clatter on about,
about their vinyl collection and knowledge of obscure Scifi shows.
Did this take place in silver lake or Brooklyn or Williamsburg?
Yeah,
but those aren't the only two hipster places.
That's true.
The guy even has this weird nub of a pony tail coming out of the bottom of his
head.
He's so cool.
He can't even have a normal pony tail.
Uh,
anyways.
Is it against the laws of men to have a barbecue without grilling any meat,
be at Burgers,
dogs,
broths,
et Cetera?
Nothing.
Anything,
nothing.
Anything against
vegetarian.
See,
after time,
not half the time,
but a third of the time,
that's the way they write it.
Not My dumb fucking brain.
Nothing to anything against.
What is he trying to say that now that I have anything against vegetarians or
their closet diets,
but I feel like something has to die for a barbecue to go on wondering what your
thoughts are on this subject.
Thanks.
And Go frog yourself.
Um,
yeah,
you basically went to a barbecue where all they had was decides,
you know what I mean?
They had the zoo Katie and they had all that type of shit.
Um,
I the,
I think a mistake that vegetarians make is they try to replace classic meat
dishes.
Yeah.
That's like,
if you went on stage,
was it Tofurky two foci?
Like it's like the fake Turkey.
Yeah.
Don't try to be Turkey and unless your Turkey,
right,
right.
Sorry.
Yeah,
like a steak doesn't try to be Zucchini.
Exactly.
Cause it could now.
It could never be so keen ever visa Keenan Zucchini needs to follow its voice.
No.
If they had an,
I mean if they had any kind of common decency,
they would have a separate little Hibachi for the the meat eaters.
I don't have sympathy for this guy.
He knew what it was.
They said it wasn't,
they did lie to him about the chicken.
We have a little bit of chicken or something like that,
but you have to bring your own food to these types of things.
You can't rely on on them.
You got to bring your own shit and just bring a cooked because yeah,
I was just saying yet though,
the steak on next to their dump,
pouring all the money,
but there'll be like,
no,
no.
I don't want it on the same thing man.
And in the mail like did you just got to bring your own shit?
You know when this,
when this idea was presented to him,
his inner voice said,
I don't want to find out where that out of that fucking shit.
You gotta listen to that,
sir,
and then you won't have to hang out with these people.
If I was ever invited to a Vegan or vegetarian barbecue,
I would say no.
Do you remember that time we had the vegetarian thanksgiving?
We tried to do that.
Oh God.
My family revolted against me and that's how I learned my lesson.
Yeah.
I was like,
I want to do a Vegan thing.
It'll be just as delicious.
It wasn't just as delicious as awful,
but we did not do it.
Yeah.
And we were trying to be really healthy.
We had just moved to La,
blah,
blah.
It's an word Douche bags,
couplet Douche.
But had we had a douchebag thanksgiving that when I spilled half of the stuffing
behind the stove and started crying.
It was that that year?
I think so.
Oh,
no,
no.
We made a vegetarian Lasagna one thanksgiving.
Oh God.
It was a terrible idea.
It's awful.
Those fucking carrots in there.
Yeah.
Carrots and Lasagna.
Terrible.
Awful.
So then I,
then,
you know what,
uh,
Jamie Masada down the laugh factory,
he has this thing where he feeds the homeless people down there and he asked me
if I wanted to do it and I was like,
no man,
it's my thanksgiving.
I don't want to,
I don't,
you know why?
I did it a couple of times and it's just like,
I don't want to fucking go down there and then you have to go on stage.
He always talks you to going on stage and you sit in there and it's a bunch of
homeless people eating and they don't give a fuck.
And you go up when your bomb.
Last time I was there I remember me and Ian Edwards just fucking eight.
It's funny to eat it on Thanksgiving,
you know,
it's a nice idea.
It's a great on paper,
on paper.
It's a great fun American comedy shows.
Well they die.
He,
they're fine.
They're fine with just the food.
Yeah,
they don't need,
they don't need to be like,
hey,
how are you guys doing?
Not Good.
We're homeless
isn't at least open bars.
And they get a,
hey,
thanks Adam.
Where are you guys from?
Fucking rail yard.
Um,
what bus station do you with at?
That's how you do yoga.
Switch up all your references.
This guy must sleep in the bus station out there in Burbank and all the other
homeless people looking down on it cause they sick fucking Hollywood.
So I ended up telling you because the vegetarian dinner was so bad.
I said,
hey,
I'm going to go down and go feed the homeless cause right cause right next door
Nikki's son of a bitch and then the next to green bland,
blessed and you ate it cold Turkey dinner.
But I walked it down and I felt so fucking guilty.
Nah,
that I ran over to the laugh factory completely full and a big smile on my face
and I fed some homeless people and Jamie's like,
you want to go and say,
it was like,
oh no.
He's like,
come on buddy.
You know it's going to be fun.
It's like Jamie,
I'm not going up and eat my balls in front of these fucking people.
They,
they're good.
They're good with the food.
I'll come up,
man,
come on now.
You did the right thing by if I having a fault,
uh,
thanksgiving by me helping the homeless was,
was horseshit that year.
I did not do it.
I went,
I didn't go down there cause I had to help the homeless.
I went down there cause I wanted to fucking Turkey dinner.
Um,
all right,
what are we up to here as far as time?
22 minutes.
We did 35,
so I'm up to 57.
All right.
Dilemma.
Uh,
another redhead joke.
Hey,
who would know,
who would thought,
would you let P diddy or anyone else that matter hit you in the head with the
kettle bell for $50 million?
Now I don't understand the point of these like random scenario questions that
people,
I suppose like would you rather get fucked in the ass bias or no?
No,
but if,
if it's,
if it's a fabric garlic oil,
like give you an if Hansel funny though.
Some of it's funny though.
If it's,
if they're funny scenarios you give,
you give somebody too awful choices.
He just said that was one said it wasn't a dilemma.
Would you do that?
Would you let P diddy and why?
Uh,
why,
why is p diddy in it?
Why is that?
What does that have to do with it?
This is the thing,
when people pull things out of their ass and I have a problem with,
it's lazy.
It's like,
see what you would do,
let Pete duty,
he would nearly go from 50 million blood.
Like what are you 13 yeah,
but I said,
no,
I'm on.
A lot of people would say yes.
Oh,
just because it for the money.
No.
If I wasn't doing what I was doing for a living and if I wasn't,
then yeah,
I'd let I let them drop it on my toe.
Yeah.
But I'm,
I'm doing all right.
So,
uh,
no,
I don't have 50 million.
I don't have anyone near that.
But I mean,
I'm not doing that.
And then somebody videotapes it.
Oh,
that big fucking kettle bell fail for the rest of my fucking life.
That was the entire,
that was the entire question.
I gotta be honest with you.
I wouldn't want to make it that way.
Make what?
Well,
why are you holding the mic?
Like you're not supposed to?
You have it.
Like you're going to sing into it.
Um,
no,
I wouldn't want to make it that way.
We'll be talking about make what,
what way?
Like all of a sudden you had 50 million bucks.
Oh,
now he's now you get yourself a little bit with a Kettlebell and he got a little
tweed coat on is some shit and then you're going to some party wherever else has
50 million bucks and they're like,
oh,
you know what?
I'm a fucking,
uh,
I dunno what,
what are they fucking my banker?
Oh,
I ran a Ponzi scheme.
You know,
something that took a little bit of effort.
American greed,
American greed.
Um,
I just find when people ask dumb questions like that,
that are meant to be some sort of probe in to usually fighting audit work,
it didn't work the way your going to give you a dilemma we give.
It's like you're not deep.
Yeah.
You're being really harsh.
Am I on the dilemma guy?
All right.
He took it.
Took it,
took a swing.
Well,
I wouldn't want people to come with a little bit more effort.
That's all.
Is it?
Is it so wrong?
But I demand excellence.
Gas.
I'm full of Shit right now.
What's the dilemma you want to pose to me then?
All right,
let me give you good.
What would you rather,
uh,
I don't know any famous people's fucking names,
so I'm going to have to describe him to you.
Oh God.
That should be good.
I'm trying to think.
I love when you,
would you identify actors?
All right.
Would you rather have sex with,
uh,
I can't even think of anybody
who's just a fucking,
just somebody.
You wouldn't want to have sex with
an actor or like,
no one astronaut
who's going to relate to them other than this shit.
Ah,
okay.
The guy in seven who got forced fed the fucking spaghettios died.
You want to talk cam?
And he's in that makeup and when he fucks,
he goes,
uh,
or,
put some jam on your Hoo Ha and let some sort of animal lick it off.
Okay?
You have to bang the fucking spaghetti.
Okay.
Until completion and uh,
and then he spends the night.
I want more.
No,
you can put some jam.
I'm going to go on,
on you.
Who are needing,
I'm going to go and that,
that'll be good.
That'll be,
that'll be over it.
And it'll be over
37 seconds.
CanNot be involved in a sexual situation with an animal on any level.
28 seconds.
It's over.
I will go with the VAT guy spending the night.
I'm not going to get into anytime.
BC Audi.
No,
no,
no.
You let it do it.
Yeah.
To you for 10 seconds.
The animal.
Okay.
No,
nothing with an animal.
No.
Absolutely not.
No nothing
ever.
Wasn't that funny?
That was funny.
That wasn't funny.
Well,
fuck.
He's not a fucking comedian.
Well,
yeah.
What you're going to do is you're gonna make everybody gun shy to fucking take a
big swinging them.
Everybody has a swing and a miss.
Oh No,
no,
no.
They're going to like tweet and send in all kinds of crazy dilemmas now,
which actually should be kind of fun.
I just don't like it when they just don't make any sense.
And then she just gave you a hacky one because they're always sexual.
So like,
cause when we were doing the dilemmas,
what happens is just became,
it just,
it just kept going sex,
would you rather fuck your mom,
dad?
It's just like Jesus Christ.
It's like watch one of those comedy central roasts were like,
by the time you get up if feel like ninth I'm one of the thing,
the level of mean you have to be.
Especially because all of those fucking roasts,
so many of them were just like the,
the comics roasting.
The person didn't know him so they didn't have any personal stories.
So it was just,
you know,
what one of those dilemmas,
but one of these dilemmas or the,
would you rather scenarios like what are these things attempting to prove?
Like yeah,
if someone's like,
would you rather have sex with your mom to be funny?
I was just supposed to be like a,
I'm,
I'm looking too much into it.
All right.
Yeah,
fair enough.
Oh jet.
Which would you rather wash dishes at Denny's or a wipe the syrup off the table
that I hop
Sarah off the tables.
Third Shift for a year.
Wait,
you can't shift.
You can't add things on.
After I answered the question,
you asked me the question.
All right.
No,
no,
no.
What you got to wipe the syrup up the fucking tables.
I'd rather dirt shift.
Third Shift when all of drunks coming into this,
a fight to when the youtube videos get made or Denny's,
you got the afternoon shift from two to five or you just got to wash all these
fucking plates,
but they're leftover.
They'll leftover from the or the morning and the lunch rush wipe off the tables,
but you'd done two to five,
two to five or you got to work a full fucking eight hours.
You come in at 10 o'clock at night and you'd done it six in the morning.
If at all I have to do is wipe down tables.
Yeah,
wipe down tables and then the other option is fucking hours or you just washed
dishes for three hours and then you have your whole fucking morning to yourself
and the whole night I might have to,
all right.
I might have to change that then.
I don't know.
It was a lot of
fucking dishes at,
I
know a dentist at Danny's,
a lot of dried syrup,
you know what I mean?
People you have to like scrape off the plates first too and all that shit.
You know like the busboys,
they just put down the,
Oh you wait,
you wait three months.
Anyone you got to clean up the fucking grease trap.
Yeah.
Something you'll never forget.
No,
I'm sticking with the wiping down the tables because then kind of have fun.
I can like chat with people.
I don't want to stand back there for three hours away and people like,
I've seen people blow their nose and like put the Napkin like on the plate and
all kinds of disgusting shit.
Like I'm not touching that.
I'll why put on a pair of gloves and I'll wipe down the table.
Spray some fucking antiseptic or whatever.
You get home with six,
you leave at six,
you get home at seven in the fucking morning.
You're so fucking wired.
You can't go to bed until 10 and eight and then you fucking sleep until what,
three,
four o'clock in the afternoon.
Then he got to go back in at 10.
It's just you have no fucking life.
Feel like one of those,
like that guy who's,
who's in the Paparazzi movie.
Hey,
I'm going to take your picture and then kill my friend.
What you talking about?
Movies?
I would say keep fixer and
I love that movie too.
Well,
it's like all Paparazzi nocturnal nightmares.
Um,
Ooh.
Did have coal houser in it?
No,
that was,
it was,
it was the one,
it was the,
um,
he was the one with Gordon East.
East,
east.
And if it's
not one of those crazy Jake Gyllenhaal.
Oh,
Jake Gyllenhaal.
Yeah.
Night Night Stalker night crawler crawler.
You weren't,
you were describing nightcrawler this whole time and we take your picture and
I'm going to kill my friend.
What did you think I was talking about?
You did this single wire,
single white female.
I thought there was a movie called Papa Razzi.
Like a real movie called Paparazzi.
Oh yeah.
It wasn't this Cole.
How's the call?
How's there?
Okay.
All right.
Is a deal.
Would you rather get slapped in the face by coal houser
or have the spaghetti o's guy give you a hug naked?
A lot in the face.
I love coal house there.
Yeah,
I was enough to let him slap you in the,
it's going to end up on youtube cause I feel like it might lead to something
else on one of those.
You know what?
I'm so tired.
Let me give a shit that you said.
Fuck
she's all yours,
Cole.
I'm want to deal with this fucking thing.
Or have the Nicky gaffers that men giving me.
These are good now because if you actually chose the hug then I was going to add
while he's softly wept into the nape of your neck.
All right.
I have to ask you one now.
Oh Jesus.
Okay.
Would you rather,
uh,
take an etiquette glass with Martha Stewart,
Martha Stewart?
It was trying to think of they I hang with her in a second or uh,
would you rather a Mazda?
What was it like when you went to jail
or would you rather do a dance recital with Ellen degenerate?
Oh my God.
No,
no fucking there's no,
there's not even a,
you wouldn't want to do a dance recital with Allen.
You'd rather sit through an etiquette class.
Martha Stewart.
No,
I can't go with my list.
I can't watch la character crowd.
You what you do with it.
Cause cause I know she's a fucking standup comic and maybe she did it a couple
of times cause she thought it was fun and now they expect him to do it right.
So she has to do it and not just get people coming up to her and restaurants.
Like I love to dance.
Oh yeah,
she probably hates it.
He probably thinks about murder suicides every fucking time it happens.
I see it in the rice I own.
I watched that a part of me dies.
Part of my soul fucking dies when I,
every time I watch her fucking do that.
It's just like,
it's your show.
You don't have to do that.
Would you rather be grilled about your comedy by Oprah Winfrey or the or,
or,
or just as guest host on the view.
What's the other view is the,
Oh,
I could have for the whoopie and I think as Rosie Perez on there now,
we have so much fun in the view.
I would just keep bringing up feminist things.
Just say,
I don't understand what the problem is just to see how mad I could make joy.
[inaudible] she's not on there anymore or is she?
I don't know.
I don't,
I would just,
I would just act like a fucking idiot and be like,
no,
I'm just asking.
Would you rather go on the road with Guy Fieri,
eating all the food and just doing all that with him?
Get a sunburn and that word or,
uh,
would you,
I'm already out
cause I wouldn't want to get in the car with him afterwards and hear what he
says about all this week.
Jesus Christ.
It fucking sucked man.
It be careful what you wish for our daughters is going to be fucking fun.
I mean,
I know make them money and everything,
but I,
if I hear one more fucking sloppy Joe,
I swear to God.
Oh,
would you rather dress up like Mario Batali and like,
you know,
go to book signings with him as like a little comedic relief.
Hey,
is my a mini me?
Yeah,
you're the [inaudible] mini me because that's tied into me as a comedian.
I have to get sunburned with Guy Fieri.
I just fuck with him the whole time.
Just suddenly
guy wanting to talk about hair or anything,
but you know,
it's a very loose,
can you stop wearing your sunglasses on the back of your head?
I know that was quite as he do that because he's part of that generation that
got the Barb wire tattoo on your arm.
Doesn't he look like he was in that band?
It was that one.
I'm,
Hey,
now you're a rock star.
Get your game on.
Go play or whatever.
What is the name of that group?
Smash Mile Smash mouth,
Wayne.
He looks like he should be in smash mouth or are they the same ones that sang
mad is where I'll be.
Well,
I can't not wham.
Yeah.
Or like who was dank or something like that.
No listing.
Who was saying is not
Sam.
Why does this,
that's amazing.
The reason I think I liked that song.
I don't know Neil.
I have no idea.
I don't know anything about that whole time during music I was doing stand up so
much.
I have no idea who,
who was staying?
Three Mary for vague link one 82 I know where they are.
I liked him.
I don't know why everybody shits on Travis Barker is a fucking drummer.
He's an incredible drummer.
He's a fucking great drama and never just leave.
I don't know.
I don't know what it was.
What it was was there was a lot of young kids that thought he was the greatest
fucking drummer because he was playing you in a pop band.
So they just knew who he was.
Right.
So then all of a sudden because they thought he was the greatest,
it's all of a sudden Travis Barker said he was better than John Bonam,
which he never did.
So we got the drummer from nine inch nails.
Sorry to interrupt.
Oh yes.
How about we met the drummer from nine inch nails and his lovely girlfriend
karody English.
Who I got to you.
You name dropping all over the phone too.
If you watch the cycles.
Seven of America's next top model.
She won.
I'm sorry,
I'm,
I'm girling nerding out right now,
but all the way over and we got an early fall.
I know.
All right.
All right,
Nia,
would you rather
all right,
I got to come up with a good one here.
Would you rather not a good one.
Uh,
flying a plane around the world.
It's a fucking one of those old propeller ones where you sit in the back with
the single seat right next to the bathroom and it already smells before it takes
off.
How you rather do that or uh,
oh Jesus.
How do I top that one?
Would you rather do that or,
oh,
I get nothing.
It's too fucking late.
God,
Jesus built off fucking clothes like this.
Now I'm just taking it to,
and someone a train fly around.
So fly around the world and like the worst seat on the airplane.
Yeah.
It's going to take it like fucking four days to do it.
Okay.
You need to do that.
Or a lane lane in a nice comfy bed and watch American greed
laying as comfy bed and watch American greed.
Let's fucking do that.
Alright,
go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.
Thank you for listening and thank you to everybody who came out on this tour.
Man,
I had a great time and uh,
I will see you next time.
And uh,
that's it.
All right.
See Ya.